how does the new Apple silicon Mac Pro
compare to my fifteen thousand dollar
Intel Mac Pro well I did a ton of
testing on this brand new model just
came out and today we will see how much
faster is it and for a lower price now
eight thousand dollars seems like a
crazy price for this when you compare it
to the Mac Studio and I made a video on
that but my Intel base Mac Pro that
thing had 192 gigs of RAM it had a Vega
2 graphics card that cost twenty eight
hundred dollars by itself I also spent
two grand for the afterburner card I
upgraded to 12 cores and here's how it
compares to this one so the price tag is
almost half now yes I do have less Ram
in this new model because with a unified
memory it's way more efficient the only
thing I upgraded is to the full unbend
M2 Ultra chip so let's go ahead and get
started testing the new geekbench 6 as
far as single core score the Apple
silicon one is more than twice as fast
and in multi-core score you guys see
once again more than twice the
performance now I'm not just going to be
writing benchmarks here I have a ton of
real world tests so as far as web
browsing performance once again we have
about two and a half times the
performance and let me tell you the new
Apple silicon model is super Snappy
compared to the Intel one which is
slower than an M1 MacBook Air now
compressing xcode used to take 20
minutes on my Intel one and now it takes
six minutes yes way faster and
uncompressing went from five and a half
minutes down to one and a half minutes
so so fast and denoising audio files
which we do every day went from 45
seconds to 12. yes we have basically
half the price and the performance
difference is almost 4X so the new
system is incredible and running figma a
web-based web design application using
this project which was provided by 500
designs one of the best design studios
in California the Apple silicon machine
runs super smoothly everything loads
really quickly and then exporting 12
high-resolution web pages takes a minute
and 38 seconds on the new Mac Pro
compared to four and a half minutes on
the old Mac Pro yes that is a massive
difference now as far as graphics
performance the M2 Ultra Graphics it's
built into the same chip which is built
in with the memory all in one compared
to that massive Vega 2 that had 32 gigs
of memory just by itself in terms of
metal performance and geekbench we have
000 for the latest version which which
went up compared to 224
000 so that is a big difference this is
RTX high-end levels of graphics
performance but the crazy thing is if we
look at pure metal gaming performances
at a compute in gfx bench we go from 205
frames per second to
629. that is over three times the
performance but what blows my mind even
more is that the Intel Mac Pro Used 250
watts to do this compared to 70. so we
have three times at performance and
three and a half times less power usage
meaning we go from 0.8 frames per second
per watt to 9 over 11 times the
efficiency which is crazy and with that
the fans are idle and the system is
running crazy cool now pushing the CPUs
to their limits in cinebench my old Mac
Pro scored 14
18103 which used to be great even years
after it came out but the M2 ultra bass
one scores 28
898 over double the CPU performance and
with that it only uses 65 watts of power
compared to 185 Watts which actually
peaked at 218 but I'm not gonna count
I'll count the consistent power usage
and that means that we get 76 points per
watt compared to
444 so Apple silicon is incredibly
efficient now let's talk about heat and
fan noise the system is exactly the same
a massive 40 or so pound system that is
crazy good quality the box is over 32
pounds I mean it's insane and we still
have those three massive fans in the
front we have another one on the side
and these fans do practically nothing
with the new one even pushing either CPU
or Graphics even both to their limits
the fans run at idle now previously the
fans would spin up and send a bench and
our temperatures would be around 85
degrees celsius compared to now we're at
76 with the fans completely at the
slowest speed possible it is insane now
with that I have to mention that you can
get the same M2 Ultra in a Mac Studio
and I did the full CPU comparison
previously if you guys want to watch how
that compares with some graphics as well
and temperatures that's a separate video
the link at the end now if you're
somebody that codes running our xcode
Benchmark that was designed for us which
is quite tough the old one was actually
quite fast 125 seconds but the new Mac
Studio took 67 seconds almost twice as
fast to do so now the insane thing is if
you got the very best 28 core processor
you're maxing at the Mac Pro you're
spending 30 grand or more with ram up to
I think over 50 Grand that was actually
90 seconds with the best processor
before and now the cheapest one even the
7000 base model takes 67. it is pretty
sweet now for music production this is
where the Intel Mac Pro was still better
than every other Apple silicon chip
including the M2 Max the M1 Ultra it was
so stable but this new M2 Ultra actually
did 320 tracks instead of
215. you guys can look up the New Logic
Benchmark yourself to see all the
details that go into it but the weird
thing was actually that the CPU wasn't
even maxed out so I think for this test
if I did upgrade the RAM to 128 it would
go even higher this is just Overkill
unless you're doing insane things now
this is where I want to mention the new
PCI slots that are in this Mac Mac Pro
it's PC Express four it has double the
bandwidth that means that you can put in
super fast ssds you can also put in
audio cards which is why a lot of people
would get a Mac Pro instead of a Mac
Studio and the old one had a bunch of
slots the new one has that as well but
it is pretty much empty out of the box
now unfortunately one thing that a lot
of people don't know and what I found
out recently is that the PCI Express 4
bandwidth is actually split between
those different slots so Apple kind of
cheaped out and even though we have
double the bandwidth overall if you're
putting in a bunch of cards you have to
watch out because it gets cut and it
will split in between and so even if one
card doesn't need that many well other
ones will suffer and that is a downside
with the system with that where we used
to have Ram like in my previous one that
was upgradable it is no longer
upgradable but they moved ssds there
where you no longer have air flow and
even though it says these are upgradable
you have to buy apples which is crazy
crazy expensive so there are a lot of
kind of little limitations with this new
system that otherwise previously we kind
of had less now in terms of photo
editing the previous Mac Pro was a beast
because it had six Channel memory that
helped it a lot now we're not running
standard channels we have unified and in
the test the macro used to destroy in we
have 542 megapixel raw edited images
that took 10 minutes and 55 seconds with
the updated version of Lightroom well
now it takes three minutes and 14
seconds
absolutely insane performance for photo
editors with that I also tested out
Affinity 2 which is very well optimized
and built from the ground up for unified
memory and here in terms of our CPU
score we have over two and a half times
the performance in terms of Graphics
metal score once again over two and a
half times the performance which is
crazy because it's pretty much half the
price but what is insane is if you're
doing things that use both CPU based
tests and GPU based tests that is where
systems started to struggle and here we
have almost seven times the performance
because this system doesn't slow down
that much when it has to switch between
both it is incredible now in terms of
blender 3D rendering the BMW test was
flying taking just 11 seconds compared
to 42. close to four times the
performance and then the much tougher
party tug test here it took 30 seconds
compared to a minute and 52. once again
close to four times the performance and
the crazy thing is blender is not yet
fully optimized for Apple silicon
they're slowly making improvements and
that is is the best that you can get
with the Intel version now with that the
memory bandwidth is over two and a half
times compared to what the Intel version
can do so the actual memory speeds and
stuff are much faster on the Apple
silicon version let's go into video
editing which is the reason why I spent
so much money on the Intel model it was
so much faster than anything else that
was available but now if we look at
stabilizing a one minute 4K clip which I
do all the time it literally takes four
seconds compared to 14 and the crazy
thing is two of those seconds is just to
start it and finish it it is insane and
exporting a standard five minute 4K
project which a lot of people do we went
from two and a half minutes down to 42
seconds that is insane now for those of
you guys that use DaVinci Resolve well
previously it was actually slightly
lower with the Intel based Mac Pro now
it is slightly faster we have 37 seconds
this thing literally exports at over 200
frames per second and what's crazy is
that it is only using 65 of the graphics
that means that the bottleneck are
actually the insanely fast encoders not
the graphics performance so if you don't
want to spend the extra thousand bucks
for the admin version you won't see a
difference and that also means that if
you're working on say a 20 minute
project it will take roughly two minutes
to export it this is no longer something
that will ever slow you down just
standing up getting some water bam you
are done as I mentioned I bought the
afterburner card for the Intel Mac Pro
because it helped a ton with prores that
thing was two thousand dollars and
instead of taking 2 minutes and 45
seconds to export a five minute project
it took a minute and 15. so almost twice
as fast and then when you're editing it
will take that load off the CPU people
loved this two thousand dollar card but
the M2 Ultra has that built in and
instead of taking a minute and 15 it
literally takes 32 seconds you just see
it flying through the export as you are
watching and that is included for free
now my Intel Mac Pro stuttered with 10
bit 422 footage it couldn't handle it no
matter what where the new one of course
it plays back perfectly smooth it barely
even notices it and trying to export a
five minute project previously would
take 8 minutes and 21 seconds now we're
down to two minutes and five seconds
basically four times the performance and
previously I had to transcode this
footage so 30 minutes of footage to
prores would take 30 minutes when that
wasn't that bad compared to the other
Max but now it takes eight minutes to do
so but you don't have to do that because
well it plays back perfectly fine
another thing that Intel Mac Pro was
killer at was denoising footage in
DaVinci Resolve it was still better than
other systems including the M1 Ultra but
now instead of getting 18 frames per
second we get a perfect 24 frames per
second playback which means that you can
do it in real time with really tough
denoising but the crazy thing is it only
used about 80 percent of the GPU it
wasn't even maxed out like it is for
every other system and that means that
you can even do so at 30 frames per
second with perfect playback which blew
my mind I didn't expect it to run so
well and that's thanks to the better
memory and the controllers in the M2
Ultra compared to the M1 Ultra with that
AK red Raw plays back perfectly at full
resolution on the M2 Ultra Mac Pro which
previously it could not do it would
stutter you'd have to lower resolution
things like that but it is amazing that
it does so and exporting this well well
it's almost twice as fast showing off
that graphics performance in this new
system that actually scales better than
what we see in simple benchmarks and as
far as AKA Cannon raw graded that also
would not play back perfectly but now it
does without any issues so this new M2
Ultra Mac Pro well it is absolutely
crazy not only is the price tag about
half compared to mine you get way better
performance than even the 28 core
version with the high-end graphics card
now yes they do have a better graphics
card that you would be able to upgrade
to later but the price tags were insane
the performance was better but not
touching this system here for a lot less
and realistically if I would have got
the base seven thousand dollar one well
the performance will still be very close
to what we are seeing here so the other
thing that blows my mind is that the Mac
Studio still has has this performance in
very low temperatures so if you guys
want to see that comparison it is right
over there and if you guys want to see
how the binned M1 Ultra compares to the
thousand dollar more unbinned make sure
you hit that Circle above to subscribe
let me know your thoughts down below and
I will see you in the next video
foreign